翻訳: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（手回しオルゴール演奏）
（手回しオルゴール演奏終わり）
（拍手）
ただ今聞いていただいた曲は
パッヘルベル作曲の『カノン』でした
私は普段は
デジタル音響機器の開発をしています
音には昔から興味があって
音響文化の研究を続けてきました
今日はその中の１つ
手回しオルゴールについて
お話ししたいと思います
このオルゴールは1970年
日本のオルゴールメーカーによって
開発されました
沢山の穴の開いた 紙のカードが
楽譜になっています
ハンドルを手で回すと
楽譜が送られて 曲が演奏できます
通常のオルゴールは
１曲または数曲しか演奏できませんが
このオルゴールは
紙のカードを変えれば
何曲でも 演奏することができます
現在 多くの編曲家によって
沢山の曲目のカードが制作されています
皆さんがおなじみのオルゴールは
ゼンマイ式ですよね
ゼンマイを回して—
カリカリカリって回して
そうすると音が鳴り始めます
ずっと同じ調子で音が鳴ってますね
それに対してこの手回しオルゴールは
ハンドルを回す
この回し加減によって
曲に表現が生まれます
曲の始まりはゆっくりと
途中から ちょっとテンポアップして
そして 最後は
ゆっくりとリタルダントして
曲を終える
そうです ハンドルを回す動作は
演奏行為なんですね
ですからゼンマイ式オルゴールが
「自動再生装置」であるのに対して
この手回しオルゴールは
「自動演奏楽器」と言えるでしょう
ハンドルを回すだけですから
絶対に音を間違えることはありません
誰にでも簡単に演奏できます
簡単そうに見えますが
良い演奏しようとすると
ちょっとだけこれ難しいんですね
私もこれ今日やるまでに
沢山沢山 練習してきました
でも難しいからこそ やっぱり楽しい
なかなか 奥の深い楽器です
オルゴールの音色には
誰もがうっとりすると思います
この独特の澄んだ音色と長い余韻
これに人は
自然に耳をすまして聞き入ってしまいますね
そして オルゴールの音色は
人の思考を
さまたげない傾向があるようです
沢山の楽器や
歌声の入ったBGMに比べて
オルゴールならば
おしゃべりや読書が
簡単にできてしまいますね
オルゴールは
音の風景としても 機能するのです
私の忘れられない体験を
お話ししましょう
あるワークショップで
４歳の女の子が—ごめんなさい
４歳の男の子が
このオルゴールをゆっくり
回してきたことがあります
この子です
どうやら彼は 自分の知らない曲を
演奏していたみたいなんですね
で 周りにいる大人は
曲を上手に演奏してほしいわけですから
もっと速く回してくれないかなぁと
思っちゃうんですけども
本人はそんなこと関係ないんです
本人はね 曲よりも
オルゴールの音
そのものを楽しんでいるんです
ゆっくりゆっくり
音のひと粒ひと粒を味わうように
丁寧に回して
そうやって楽しんでいました
ゼンマイ式では絶対にできない
手回しならではの楽しみ方ですね
次に私が開発した
新しいオルゴールを紹介しましょう
私は
イタズラが大好きなんです
ある時この楽譜の代わりに
絵や文字を書いて 鳴らしてみたんです
今日ここに
『TEDx』—
ティー、イー、ディー、エックスと
書いたカードを
作って持ってきました
鳴らしてみますね
（オルゴールの音）
いきますよ
（手回しオルゴール演奏）
え...
いかがですかね...
（拍手）
いや ここは拍手するとこ
じゃないんですよ
（笑）
あの 悪くはないんだけども
まああんまり聞きたくはない音楽ですよね
はい その通りだと思います
赤ちゃんが弾くピアノのように
デタラメ音楽ですから 当然です
ではこの同じカードを
こちらのオルゴールで鳴らしてみましょう
いきますよ もう１回『TEDx』という曲です
（手回しオルゴール演奏）
今度はどうですか？
（拍手）
懐かしいメロディーが
聞こえてきましたでしょうか
これは 日本の童謡 それから民謡
それからスコットランドの民謡なんかでも
使われている音階なんです
実はこれ １オクターブに５つの音—
ド、レ、ファ、ソ、ラで調律した
５音階手回しオルゴールなんです
通常は ドレミファソラシの７音ですが
それを５音にすること によって
多少でたらめでも こうやって
心地よい音を楽しむことができます
ではこの同じカードを使って
次はこちらのオルゴールで演奏してみますね
もう１回『TEDx』という曲 です
（手回しオルゴール演奏）
聞こえてきましたか？
（拍手）
いかがですか？
南の島の風の音が
聞こえてきましたでしょうか？
これは 沖縄琉球の音階なんです
あるいはインドネシアの音楽にも
使われている音階です
このように ５音階手回しオルゴールを使うと
これまでは 全然聞くに堪えなかった
絵や文字の楽譜が
このように美しい音楽となって
聞くことができます
これまで紹介してきたオルゴールは
決して 私１人で作ったわけではありません
このオルゴールに関わった
素晴らしい人たちが—
この人たちです
左の女性は
オルゴールの編曲家です
豊かな感性とそれから オルゴールならではの
編曲テクニックを駆使して
数多くの作品を 世に提供しています
最初に聞いていただいた
『カノン』も彼女の作品です
真ん中の男性は
サウンドボックスの製作家です
オルゴールの乗っている この台も
彼の作品です
オルゴールのメカの持っている
可能性を極限まで引き出して
最高の響きの音を聞かせてくれます
右側の男性は
オルゴールの設計者です
５音階の調律を引き受けてくれました
この特殊な調律には
解決しなければならない問題が
たくさんありました
本当に苦労されたそうです
彼は 未来に向けた新しいオルゴールの
開発に取り組んでいます
今日 私はこの手回しオルゴールから
３つのことを提案したいと思います
１つは
「質を追求する」という点です
たかがオルゴールですが
ひとつひとつの要素を
追求して洗練することによって
これほどの 音色に
仕上げることができました
この音色の素晴らしさは
最初に皆さんが『カノン』で
お聞きになった通りです
２番目は
「従来の型を破る」という点です
これまでの常識を超えて
「絵」や「文字」を楽譜にして
そして５音階手回しオルゴールでは
それを素晴らしい音に
奏でられることを見ていただきました
最後は
「誰でも楽しめる」という点です
音楽や楽器の演奏が苦手な方でも
手回しオルゴールならば
誰でも素敵な演奏家になることができます
さらには ５音階手回しオルゴールでは
素晴らしい作曲家にもなることが出来ます
小さいお子様から お年寄りの方まで
体の不自由な方でも
これまでの枠を取っ払って
自由に穴を開けて
そしてくるくる回してみてください
そこには 難しい演奏技術も
音楽理論もいりません
ただ 音を楽しむ—
その気持ちだけがあればいいんです
私は今日は
手回しオルゴールの話をしましたが
このようなことは 皆さんの
身のまわりにもあるかもしれませんね
ひとつひとつの要素を洗練して
究極の品質に高めることによって
これまで 当たり前と感じていたことが
違って見えてくるかもしれません
そして 伝統的な型を—
打ち破って
新しい要素を取り入れることによって
新しい可能性を見出すことができるでしょう
是非 皆さんも ご自身の
手回しオルゴールを見つけてください
（拍手）